you've gone through the migration
process and are ready to move your first
microservice to GAE in today's episode
let's see how
[Music]
[Applause]
let's consider the ice cream theory
which is an online ice-cream parlor
there on this journey to migrate their
monolith websites of micro-services and
they're looking for guidance and moving
their first micro-service gke so we'll
walk them through the migration and
stages well we'll need to run an
assessment of their current environment
to determine how many public endpoints
we will need and what needs to move but
we'll get to that in the next episode
for now let's assume that they have
picked up a feature that makes sense to
start with this migration before we
start converting their chosen feature to
a micro service on gke let's see how to
prepare the GCP environment well before
they migrate the legacy components they
will need a place to put them and for
that they will need a GCP organization
then they need to ensure that only
people if the right authorization can
access the resources so they need to
design GCP policies to control access to
the GCP resources and once that's taken
care of it's time to create a plan to
deploy the resources in a standardised
reproducible way using infrastructure as
a code utilizing tools like deployment
manager and terraform at this point we
recommend the ice cream theory team to
study gk and its features so that they
can tweak them for their needs this will
mean changing some of GK's defaults and
maybe hardening the cluster security
once GK is set up it's time to build the
CI CD pipeline they can use their
existing tools like spinnaker or Jenkins
or they can use the GCP products like
cloud build and container registry to
build store and scan those container
images doing this early in the project
will avoid problems when they are in
production and remember the last episode
where we discussed communication options
between Google cloud and on-premises
data centers well they would need to
decide whether an API based solution
like Apogee or a private connection like
cloud interconnect is better for their
needs now that we have our GCP
environments set up which is kind of
like preheating the oven to start the
actual cooking it's time to start
migrating the legacy platform over to
GCP overall we recommend that ice cream
Theory migrate their features of the
website one by one to the new
environment creating micro services will
require those
services can call back to the legacy
system whenever they need my greeting in
stages like this has two advantages
smaller projects are easier to work with
minimize errors and costly mistakes and
it lets you handle each individual
migration without getting overwhelmed
the first thing to analyze is the
dependencies of the shopping cart
feature on the rest of the system we can
do that by reasoning through the steps
the user takes when interacting with the
website the user makes ice-cream
selection and clicks add to my shopping
cart that triggers an API call from the
users browser to the shopping cart once
the shopping cart receives the call it
checks whether the chosen ice-cream is
in stock by making an API call to the
inventory system if the item is in stock
the shopping cart stores info something
like Carter has one instance of items
strawberry ice cream in the cart finally
when the user checks out and goes
through the payment process the shopping
cart is queried by the payment subsystem
to compute the total and once the
payment is complete the payment
subsystem notifies a shopping cart
feature to empty the cart so if we
analyze this at a high level this
shopping cart feature has four
dependencies it is caught by the front
end and the payment subsystem and it
queries a database and the inventory
system now that we have identified the
dependencies let's give some thought to
the choice of database for this feature
a document database is very suited for
storing shopping carts since shopping
carts can be easily indexed by user IDs
and you don't need the power of
relational database here cloud fire
store is a great fit for this purpose
it's managed and serve unless no sequel
document database so let's consider that
for our target architecture
now comes the biggest piece migrating
the actual shopping cart feature
assuming ice cream theory can schedule a
maintenance for their website wait wait
wait I don't know when is downtime for
ice creams I know I can eat ice creams
in the middle of the night I know let's
say that they can do scheduled
maintenance first they would need to
create a new micro service that can call
the inventory system and uses cloud fire
sword implement a shopping cart API then
create a script that extracts shopping
cart entries from the legacy shopping
cart system and writes them the cloud
fire store this
group needs to be written in a way that
it can be rerun as many times as needed
but only copies of shopping carts that
have been changed since last time then
create a script that does the opposite
which is it copies shopping carts from
cloud fire store back to the legacy
subsystem in case they need to rollback
the migration then expose the shopping
cart API with Apogee they would need to
prepare and test the modification to the
front-end and payment systems so they
can call the new shopping cart system
again comes the time to run the data
migration script we prepared earlier so
all the data is in sync and we do not
lose any shopping card records in the
process at this point they need to put
their website in maintenance mode and
rerun the data migration script deploy
the test and modifications done to the
front end in the payment system on the
legacy production system once done
they're ready to disable the maintenance
mode in the website and with that the
shopping cart feature of the ice cream
theory website is now microservice
hosted on Google Cloud the hardest step
of this process is where they had to
make changes to the legacy payment and
front-end system but that gets easier as
they migrate more and more features to
micro services because more and more the
dependencies will already be micro
services as such they're more loosely
coupled than in monolithic application
and are easier to modify and deploy for
more information about alternative
migration approaches check out the
article written by marco and Te'o well
there you have it if you are looking to
migrate a monolithic application to
micro services you've got a small taste
of the steps involved through the ice
cream theories useless stay tuned for
the next episode where we will talk
about deciding what to migrate first
until then try the end-to-end migration
of an e-commerce website in the codelab
link below that's all for today I'll get
cooking in cloud if you like what we're
cooking here and like to see more
recipes don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]
you